[Musique]
je veux travailler avec eux je veux
construire avec eux ce qu'ils sont en
train de construire avec les élèves
aujourd'hui voilà le message de l'élue
déléguée à l'éducation du conseil
départemental
pour cela elle rend visite ce matin là
aux trois collèges de sainte marie ça
c'est la dotation petits travaux que
j'ai justement administratif de la
direction de l'éducation des bâtiments
et espaces publics et personnels de
l'établissement échanges sans perdre de
temps
il faut dire que la collectivité est une
aide précieuse pour ce collège qui
souhaitent utiliser son environnement
proximale comme l'aéroport comme outil
pédagogique
moi ce que je peux vous assurer c'est
que vous aurez en tous les cas mon
soutiennent tout ce que vous avez
entrepris
[Musique]
départementale c'est une aide précieuse
pour les collèges tant au niveau du bâti
et bien sûr sur un certain m d'actions
pédagogiques mais plutôt éducative à
travers l'éducation la parentalité à
travers la lutte contre la violence les
incivilités et pour ça j'ai vu un
accompagnement j'ai besoin aussi des
moyens financiers j'ai besoin aussi la
participation des parents la
sensibilisation aussi aux parents assez
à ses yeux c'est parfois eux mêmes ne se
déplace pas trop donc ça serait une
dynamique et une synergie de tous
même discours au collège de beauséjour
mais pas les mêmes problématiques
par exemple ici le soleil est un atout
mais aussi une contrainte pour les 850
élèves qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'ombré
pour nos élèves malheureusement sont
dans une petite cour qui très
ensoleillée on est content du soleil
mais il ya quand même des conséquences
où elles étaient très présents dans
l'établissement
elle répond toujours aux sollicitations
établissement c'est très important pour
nous d'avoir ce proximité d'avoir cette
rencontre régulièrement réalité du
terrain réalité du monde politique
ma délégation est un tout l'éducation il
ya les élèves il ya l'équipe pédagogique
il ya ce qu il travaille il ya le
personnel polyvalent il ya des parents
c'est un tout ça forme une globalité et
dans sa globalité
il faut qu'on arrive nous à l'étrier et
à faire en sorte que chaque partie soit
respectée et entre l'état de travailler
comme il se doit dans cette partie
une oreille attentive à tous les acteurs
de ces établissements qui se conclut par
le collège jean des sme l'occasion de
rappeler les nouveaux projets de cette
mandature geste est pour vous
pendant ce temps là dans la cour les 7
106 élèves et les 105 de ses pas ne se
doutent pas qu on travaille pour leur
bien-être
nous sommes extrêmement sensibles à la
venue de madame soubadou dans notre
établissement
surtout qu'elle vient de façon très
rapide et qu'elle vient avec un dossier
très très préparée toute notre vie en
fait l'atout dolist et bien pleine pour
les agents de la collectivité et la
matinée se termine logiquement par la
cantine à son pic de fréquentation
je ne le vois pas être d'assez derrière
un bureau et attendre que ça se passe le
rôle d'un élu c'était vraiment sur le
terrain c'est le direct un bon temps et
aujourd'hui le terrain a besoin des élus
et il est 2 viril et je suis à ma place
[Musique]